[Music]
this week on q a our guest is judy
shelton economist and wall street
journal contributor
[Music]
judy shelton the last time you were in
this studio was april
around april the 9th 1989 20 years ago
i have not seen you anywhere since then
what have you been doing for the last 20
years
um
i guess i'm a hermit i'm i've still been
thinking about all the things we
probably talked about back then
and i think even back then i was
mostly interested
in issues like international monetary
reform
i was probably working only on the
soviet union
which turned into a special case of an
economy gone bad
but
i
my husband and i live on a farm
effectively just the right distance from
washington about an hour and 10 minutes
and so i like to dabble in the
intellectual and the political and the
academic
but i would say
my personality is to
just hide away in my little office with
my computer and
i'm not a big
socialite type we're going to show some
of the past uh interview that we did but
before we do that let's go through some
of just some of the basics where were
you born
los angeles
where did you go to school
in the valley
so i'm really kind of the classic uh
valley girl for sure
suburb of los angeles san fernando
valley what kind of family was it great
great family i have a great family five
kids
mom
very traditional wonderful stayed at
home took care of five kids i i don't
think i ever fully appreciated then what
a huge job that is i thought it was kind
of glamorous that my dad was a
businessman and went out the door with a
briefcase so i think i probably aspired
more that route
and then you i know you got a phd from
the university of utah uh what year was
that
81. back off of that where did you get
your undergraduate degree i went two
years to ucla
then i became miss independent left home
went to portland state university which
i quickly found out when you're paying
for your college yourself
then you just go where you can afford
and i started working and probably
that's when i got serious it was the
first time i took an economics course
from then on i was a very serious
student
i was offered a job at payne weber that
took me to salt lake city
i met my husband there i continued and
received my phd in finance
wrote a paper that some very kindly
professor
decided was
good enough to
submit on my behalf to a competition it
won as best doctoral student paper i
ended up getting a a postdoctoral
fellowship
at stanford at the hoover institution
what did you do there
i worked for a gentleman who named
martin anderson he had just come from
the
reagan administration
he gave me interesting projects without
a lot of supervision which was perfect
for me he had me researching
international debt and finance
statistics
and one of the most invaluable things i
learned right away is
probe and find out where those numbers
come from is the country providing it is
anyone overseeing it how honest are the
numbers so
you were at hoover for how long 10 years
lived there right there in palo alto no
no not really not really um
i ended up getting a fellowship to
examine in particular soviet statistics
i was looking at the world but the ones
that came up as the most interesting
numbers were on the soviet union
gorbachev had just come into power in
1985
the united states and the west were
suddenly making loans to the soviet
union new numbers were coming out about
how much they were borrowing from the
west and i propose to do a very
very boring very dry study of the impact
of western capital on the soviet economy
but as i was doing that i started
thinking
why is it that defense spending
is costing u.s taxpayers so much money
and then we're turning around with our
nato partners and making loans to this
soviet economy
and supplying goods that they might
otherwise have to divert their own
resources to making instead of building
nuclear weapons against which we were
paying a bundle to defend ourselves so
um it all became sort of a policy issue
and um so i ended up this paper turned
into a book with a very sensationalist
title called the coming soviet crash
that said
on paper
this country is going bankrupt
and then there were implications from
that that even got me involved in
defense issues so it got interesting i
remember seeing you give a speech on
this network back in 89.
since the topic before us is perestroika
who should pay for it
i thought it would be useful to take a
few minutes to lay things out the way
gorbachev must be looking at them
in terms of the economic and financial
situation in the soviet union
so that we have an overall feel for the
requirements of peer stroke the cost
in the sense of what is needed to get it
off the ground
and then we were doing the book show and
i we asked you to come and
we visited for one hour uh and i want to
show the audience and you oh no
several clips maybe before it's over uh
what you were talking about back then
and the thing that keep in mind is that
on november the 9th 1989 it was the fall
of the wall so that was 20 years ago but
let's watch and see what you were saying
back then
what do you think of the soviet union
i think that
it's an idea that went wrong
economically i
think it's doomed
i and i i don't say that with glee
i've only been to the soviet union on
one occasion for a couple of weeks
i liked it very much was treated very
nicely
some ways i'm
i'm probably a closet to slavophile i
like the russian language i work at it
every day
i like
russian literature
so
one problem with the book or at least
for me is i've had
the sense of people thinking that i
i want to see the soviet union collapse
i
don't like the soviet government i don't
like
the soviet government's emphasis on
military strength as its claim to
superpower status
i think it's misplaced
so
what do you think since then what's
what's happened to the soviet union
well i still like russia and i like
russian literature and i like the
russian people
i think what they found out was
you cannot remain a viable
country
and suppress
individual
pursuit
of prosperity or creativity or whatever
it is people want to use their god-given
talent
life liberty happiness
you cannot
subjugate that to what some greater
government decides is important and in
the soviet union they decided military
strength was the most important
second to that was infrastructure they
wanted to be
independent and they wanted to be
internally powerful and part of the
control mechanism and a very poor third
were the people themselves
and i think it it bred a sort of
hopelessness
that i still think is is the biggest
problem of
over
overreaching government have you been
back
yes a few times and now at the national
endowment for democracy
i specialize in
pro-democracy projects
in russia
what is the national endowment for
democracy
it's called ned
and the national endowment for democracy
ned was started under president reagan
but as a completely bipartisan
pro-democracy initiative
it is funded by congress through the
state department but it's independent of
the state department with an independent
board who runs it
the board and our staff and what we do
is take grant money
approximately
110 million a year
and we have this year over a thousand
projects
but we never tell people in another
country what they should be doing
to have democratic institutions that is
we think
we think the best formula for people is
democracy
and that means free independent media
fair elections honest elections
rule of law
right to assemble
the national endowment is is
comprised really well there's four core
groups and we
give grants to them but they represent
the republican party the democratic
party
chamber of commerce representing private
entrepreneurship
and labor solidarity center representing
unions who nominated you for the board
i was asked by vin weber who was the
chairman i don't know who's chairman now
he uh well it has just switched to uh
richard gephardt because they do because
it's so exquisitely politically balanced
um
they they always make sure that there's
a the same number of republicans and
democrats
there's lots of congressmen and
ambassadors who are on the board but
when the office when the white house
changes they do change from chairman to
vice chairman to reflect the party in
power do they pay you
no
do they pay the chairman
i don't think so no how big is the staff
the staff is
i think about 120 or so and they operate
on a pretty thin budget basically they
receive the grants
people in other countries apply for
grants
countries all over the world virtually
every country where there is some need
to improve the democratic process
and
they've been very active in the middle
east
but they come to us they can get on our
website and apply for a grant and then
our staff
make sure that they're legitimate and
that they have the wherewithal to
to
comply with the requirements we're very
transparent but we do a lot of good in
funding people who are willing to take
the risk
and in some countries it's it's
significant risk
to fight for democracy so anyone who's
ever been cynical
about democracy should talk to our
grantees who thank us
and who are willing to be harassed put
in jail
sometimes worse because they demand what
we have and particularly those
institutions once again
a free independent media the right to
vote in an honest election
the right to assemble
they want they want to have protests in
most countries they're not allowed give
us one example of what you would
consider a success and how long you've
been on the board
i've been on
four years i would say one of the great
successes was ukraine
ukraine the orange revolution and in
fact russia very much resented the work
of ned
in in
ned
helped support the groups that became
part of that movement the orange
revolution who said
this will not stand we know it was a
fraudulent election and they just
refused to leave the streets until there
was a runoff and that is when victor
yuschenko
was elected uh he's the man who if you
remember the toxins his whole face was
destroyed he was not the favorite
of moscow
but he rose to uh lead ukraine to head
ukraine toward
nato toward the european union
now things have been rough in ukraine
the economy has
really spiraled downward
it's a very difficult situation they're
on the border with russia
but even though
they've experienced real
political difficulties and economic
difficulties i still think that they
have said it's better to be independent
and we will decide our own destiny
and probably even leaders who we might
now say were too pro-russian at one time
they likewise say no we may decide to
move ahead with european union
integration here's more from our 20 year
old interview
now um
if i was going to advise the soviet
government from a financial point of
view what they could do to take part in
the
international international
financial system monetary system
i would urge them to
put their money where their mouth is so
to speak and and come up with a gold
back ruble
i think that the soviet union's only
claim to credibility
with western
financial
types
is to provide collateral behind a
currency in fact i think it would be a
rather
um brilliant coup on their part
to come out with the currency that they
agree to redeem in gold because they
have mythical holdings not not mythical
in the sense that they don't exist
but
bankers eyes just get round when they
think of soviet gold reserves so there
is this
implicit assumption on our part that
they do have something valuable and
clearly i think they're the world's
second largest producer they do have
gold
what's happened to their gold and their
ruble in the last 20 years well they
should have done that i have to say i
wish i had fought
harder
um i went over with a hoover team a
stanford team
in 1991
advising boris yeltsin i was given the
portfolio to recommend
whether or not russia could break free
of the soviet union it was that august
that everything fell apart
and in fact
by december of 1991
the soviet union was no more
i think that
the soviet union or what the residual
governments then decided to go with the
big bang theory and there was a harvard
approach
and
the net result was instead of
solidifying the money first they tried
to do everything
and they ended up
giving people a really bad taste for
capitalism the russian people
who were very hopeful under yeltsin
ended up thinking that this is a way for
for people who have access to the
politically elite
the cronies of those in power they'll
get big rewards and the rest will suffer
so
throughout the um the 90s
russia was really
grasping with disaster and it was only
really when
putin came to power that russia started
making money because of oil
and people started saying you know this
is better it's better to have a strong
tough leader we're even we're willing to
give up some of those freedoms we
thought were important but it turned out
we were we were worse off
under so-called capitalism and
i think even now
if your currency has integrity you can
build on it it's a foundation
and
russia ended up having a disaster in
1999 where the ruble lost a third of its
value in a matter of a few weeks
there was a complete default and it it
put russia on the lifeline to the imf
which they also resented and again it
just fueled kind of this permanent
distrust of the west which i think is
why someone like putin stays in power
you've mentioned the imf a couple times
what is it
the international monetary fund
has a wonderful legacy was set up
during world war ii
actually the first draft laying it out
was written by a guy named harry dexter
white in the treasury department
a week after pearl harbor was bombed and
the idea was to say
you know in the 30s because of the
depression we had a breakdown of any
kind of international system we had
beggar thy neighbor
competitive depreciations of currencies
where everyone tried to make their
currency cheap so they would get an
advantage when they sold it in another
country
we had protectionism
and
in order to get the allies
in europe to feel like there was
something worth fighting for
the u.s decided let's give people hope
that if we get through this vicious war
there'll be something good to come to we
won't just go back to the 30s where it
was every man for himself and a
depression
will show leadership and so the imf came
out of that the international monetary
fund had one main job and it was to have
a stable
international monetary system fixed
exchange rates among currencies they
would have to be fixed relative to the
dollar and the dollar would be
convertible into gold at a fixed rate of
35 dollars per ounce of gold
any country in the world back up its
currency with gold today
no and this is why i now
have
real resentment
of the international monetary fund
because when the u.s went off that
system under president nixon in august
of 1971
instead of fighting to maintain a stable
monetary system or figure out how to get
back to one which is what i think the
imf should have sought to do
it waited a few years kind of fumbled
along and then it accepted that and now
its attitude is
any country can have any kind of
exchange arrangement they want floating
fix they can have a currency board they
can they can piggyback and peg to
another country's currency the only
thing they can't do
is pay their money
to gold so it's not just a betrayal of
the original idea
it's it's almost perverse they can't peg
the gold meantime the imf sits on
most virtually all of the gold that was
contributed from the beginning from
countries who had to
pay in gold or dollars to become a
member of what was supposed to be a
stable international
monetary system
uh vin weber you mentioned earlier
my recollection is that jack kemp was a
big gold
supporter and he had an outfit called
empower america and that vin weber was
involved with empower america and you
were involved with pyramid i was on that
board um
very proud of that
kemp
was a visionary there was recently an
event in washington to launch the jack
kemp foundation
it's very
invigorating to see the people who were
part of that movement
the supply side
now we can proudly say supply side
was something
that brought economic growth it was
based on
the wisdom of recognizing that the free
market works
because it's it reflects the collective
effort of individuals who use their
talent and their intelligence
to pursue their dream
and what you don't want to do is inhibit
that all entrepreneurs really want
are good solid rules
a solid foundation
and honest money which is something jack
kemp
was willing to go to bat for
sound money
that to me is where you start
you're not your personal detractors but
people that would detract from or
criticize what you're saying
would say today that we are in the mess
we're in today because of supply-side
economics because of this thing that
went on during the reagan years it said
spend spend spend enjoy
you've heard it
the economic growth
during the 80s completely turned us
around from
the stagflation the stagnant growth and
the inflation the worst of all worlds
that we had under president carter
and in the 70s it looked like our
country was permanently in malaise or
even going into decline
as if we just become
in a business model kind of the cash cow
but our our best days were behind us
what we learned under
the
reagan administration was that
the potential for economic growth is
still there i know it sounds hackneyed
but the american dream is still alive
and i think a universal one
people want to be successful they want
to be prosperous
it doesn't mean just material wealth
they just want to have the chance to
pursue what matters to them and to
define what matters
to them
and
the two big parts
of the reagan revolution
were in monetary policy
to
to stabilize it to get rid of inflation
and under paul volcker
that's what we did it took
it took a real squeezing out it was very
painful
but with high interest rates we
attracted a lot of foreign capital he
was following robert mundell's ideas
mandel laffer
art laffer these are the heroes of the
supply side revolution so on monetary it
was to have a stable honest dollar
and
in the fiscal realm the idea was lower
taxes lower taxes and give people a
chance to be entrepreneurs before they
get to a an atlas shrugged point in
their life where they say it's not worth
it it's not worth it to be creative and
take risks and go out there and be an
entrepreneur
i really think when you lower taxes
you're finally recognizing the heroism
of entrepreneurs it's 20 years later and
remember back then it was all about the
soviet union here's another excerpt and
what you were thinking then
could you sense from visiting there for
the short time that the people there are
happy unhappy how would you compare them
with the general mood of americans
you know that's a um
that's a question
that i think reflects human nature i'm
i'm not sure that a
highly
consumerist society
means
greater personal happiness for an
individual
the people i met
happy enough i think they had that that
uh russian characteristic of being
resigned
i think they're much more passive than
americans we're we're so demanding if
something's not up to snuff
we call the manager uh
in the soviet union they shrug it off
and if they get lucky they're able to
buy this or that it's good fortune
but um you you wouldn't begin to see
irritation
of uh like you would in the united
states
have you seen any change in the russian
people since
the wall came down
they've had a taste
of freedom
there's still a certain
resignation
and they probably accept what's imposed
on them much more readily than americans
but
i am so glad americans don't have that
trait
we do get mad thank thank goodness we
get mad and we fight back and we have a
political system
that allows us to say we don't like the
way we're going and um
we're americans and this is a government
of the people by the people for the
people and we say we're the people and
we really start asserting it and that
there's still a difference the russians
don't quite believe it but one thing i
do think is universal
is is
the entrepreneurial spirit and and it's
not just about making money i i agree
with what i said then
if you're resigned in
it's
in any society it's not just because you
can't necessarily be the wealthiest
person it's that you can't
fulfill your own dreams and in russia in
the soviet union it was that
soul-killing
aspect of living in a society
where what you were going to do and
where you were going to live was preset
it was central planning all the way and
and
the liveliness of a dynamic society like
the us i think comes from a sense of
well we don't know exactly what's going
to happen because i might just decide to
go out and
be this or that i'm going to take the
risk i'm going to put together a plan
there's a sense of the possibility
of being successful however you define
it
that i think is uh the difference
between being a caged animal
where food is thrown to you predictably
or saying no i'm going to live in the
wild and i
might just have to fend for myself
if you like freedom
that's what you live for and that that's
what i think is worth preserving or
bringing
to bringing as a power to bear in any
society
today uh
20 years later this is a been a huge
consumer society
you hear a lot of people complaining
about service stinks wherever you go
in the u.s in the u.s
a lot of the institutions that we
revered 20 years ago have
failed miserably
all the airlines almost all of them went
broke
what do you what happened here then
i'd say wherever competition is limited
you're going to see a decline in service
and value
it's competition
adam smith who had a great sense of
morality
he wrote about that as much as he did
about
how capitalism would work if the
invisible hand sort of directed
individuals to do things he said that
would ultimately give you the best
society and i think it's really true
um
maybe it even seems selfish that people
trying to enrich themselves cater to the
demands
of other people but but
what else would we want it's it's people
who are willing to
to set up a service business or produce
something and
they're trying to
please their fellow man yes because he's
going to buy the product and they'll
make a profit and that's how they'll
they'll do better economically
but it's also a society that pays
attention to
its fellow man
because that person
demands the best value for the lowest
price and it brings to bear all of the
forces of free markets and that's what i
believe in i think that comes closest to
reflecting a system that
individual humans can can thrive within
you have not i've not seen you on
television
do you not do these shows for a reason
well i was especially pleased to do your
show because i think
it's it's nice to
speak in depth i appreciate that
opportunity i don't think i'm a good
sound bite person
because i'm likely to say something that
maybe is taken the wrong way i'm not
sure but do you avoid them on purpose
i'm i don't avoid them but i don't often
accept i i kind of
the wall street journal
a blessed newspaper has been very kind
especially in the last couple of years
giving me a great
forum to get ideas out there but i'm
i like
i know we need strong political
personalities
so you need people with charisma
but i think i'm much more the kind who
is sitting in jeans and t-shirt and
pounding away on my keyboard
and i don't even try to sell my ideas so
much as i'll just slide it under the
door
and if people
like it i'm happy to come in i sometimes
will come in and meet with senators at
the capitol and um tell them my thoughts
about the debt situation or the deficit
or where we're going as far as the
dollar i love to do that but more as a
behind the scenes um
yeah teacher i guess
not the doer the teacher so david walker
who used to run the gao government
accountability office and now runs the
pete peterson foundation
says that we cannot grow out of the
situation we're in now
it's pretty frightening is that true and
if it is is it the first time in our
history
i never want to say we can't
because we've been in
terrible situations coming out of world
war ii
we had a lot heavier debt to
gross domestic product ratio
we've had tough times before
where we're confronted with the
the loss of war
financially as well as
what it does to the spirit
um but i think the country is valiant
i want to say
resilient enough to come out of even
this but this is unprecedented
spending unending deficits and what i
consider an unconscionable
accumulation of debt it's a kind of debt
that thomas jefferson said was the last
thing he ever wanted to wish on this
country where
the the burden the yoke on the necks of
american citizens
is set by government without really
their express permission i guess
i guess we give our implicit permission
because we elect the people we do
but it's a tremendous
debt level and i think at some point you
can kill
the goose that laid the golden egg at
some point
i can well imagine the creative
productive
people who have brought tremendous
profits and salaries and built factories
and made other people wealthy
i can see an atlas shrug scenario where
they all say i'm going to gulz gulch i'm
dropping out i'm going on strike because
the country doesn't appreciate
the risk i take on and how hard i work
and the government takes me for granted
i can imagine people saying
it was a great dream but
i don't know if it's worth it for me and
if enough people feel that way then the
country has real problems which
politicians have been the most
consistent for you in your life that you
have any respect for
certainly jack kemp
um
i like john kyle of arizona jim demint
south carolina
those people come to mind i'm very
pleased with bob mcdonnell i've met him
our new governor of virginia very
pleased that he is talking about free
enterprise
and
the american dream i i
those would be the people who come to
mind
which economist you know the in the paul
volcker alan greenspan
group do you respect the most
the greatest
economist the one for whom i have the
most respect
is robert mundell
where is he is he alive he is a
professor at columbia he won the nobel
prize in 1999 he is the father of supply
side economics he also has a magnificent
castle in siena italy with his wife
valerie and their young son
and
every year and i believe he's done this
since 1971 since the dollar went off of
gold
he has a fantastic gathering of
economists from all over the world
talking about
how can we ever get back to
a stable international monetary system
and he has people like paul volcker in
attendance i've met many central bankers
and leaders of government there and so
he's very much involved still
in the future of the international
monetary system he's been consistent
intellectually
and he's very interested in china these
days he sees china
as uh coming on board just as he
supplied the intellectual groundwork for
the creation of the the euro
the european money
and he now sees we could have some kind
of a um a linkage between the euro the
dollar and whatever china comes up with
some kind of a
yuan that's convertible and a stable
currency explain something this is a
simple thing
i mean it's not simple explanation i'm
sure but
when the euro was created and was was
that 10 years ago
yes
there was a parody
one dollar for one euro yeah
and then it even dipped below
where it was in the 80s on the euro side
and now it's a dollar fifty
the other way around now that tells you
something because the whole idea of
floating rates
was supposed to be a more stable system
and um
and the whole idea of fighting
protectionism is to eliminate tariffs
but because you have this huge area of
the the european union and this huge
area the united states
having
variations of of 50 percent more than 50
percent in that relatively limited time
span
that tells you that
the swing in
currencies swamps
the impact of a tariff of
five percent maybe 10 percent when you
have a swing of a currency of 50 percent
you have just made your competitors
products fifty percent more expensive
which is completely unfair if you really
believe in a global marketplace in a
level playing field
or you've given yourself an advantage
which is certainly on the scale of the
great depression
when we called it bigger thy neighbor
these competitive devaluations the u.s
now having a weak dollar
to me is saying
to the rest of the world we don't care
we may be cheating because a weak dollar
makes our products
cheaper in your markets but we're doing
it that's very unseemly
for our country such a wealthy country
to do that
one of the things amateurs like me don't
know is who's making the money and i
assume somebody in this country with
this weak dollar
is benefiting greatly well the problem
is because there's no system
uh money doesn't mean what it's supposed
to mean it's supposed to be a unit of
account a measure an honest measure it's
supposed to be a store of value
instead it's become
a game
the people who make money are
speculators who bet on where the dollar
is going to go relative to the euro or
other currencies and you have banks
banks betting now banks have to be able
to exchange money because they handle
international trade but the amount of
money you would have to convert into
another currency to carry out
international trade is like less than
five percent of the currency
market the foreign exchange market is
huge and it's absolutely just a gamble
of betting which way it's going to go
so banks get big profits from that
speculators get big profits but what
bothers me is that we've turned money
into
into a lottery instead of money being a
tool and i think the most important tool
for capitalism which requires free
markets
how do you interpret demand and supply
for anything
if you have the sliding
measure
of of what its price is
it would be like having a ruler and
today an inch is this big and tomorrow
it might be like that you can never
have this reliable way to measure value
so how can free markets work when you
don't have a unit of account that means
the same
and through time to everyone you don't
have that basic foundation
upon which price signals can then do
their job and free markets can work and
you're married to a banker
i am well a former banker a wonderful a
very brilliant finance and
monetary
intellect
who was a very successful banker but who
lucky for me got out of banking
back in the early 80s and so
is
kind of a fellow farmer we both like to
hang around
the place
and go out and visit the cows and this
morning he was up
in a tree stand watching deer didn't
shoot any but i'm sure we'll end up
having
venison tonight so
it's a different life it's not a
washington life
you did spend time in mexico though yes
i taught at a great school it was a
business school a graduate school of
business called dukes it was started by
a great man named alfonso romo one of
the
billionaire billionaires of mexico but
more important a man who whose
grandfather was
was the president of mexico the first
democratically elected president of
mexico in the 20s he was assassinated
but this man cares very much about the
legacy of democracy and entrepreneurial
capitalism and this graduate school of
business he set up in monterey mexico
had all u.s and european faculty who he
would fly in you would take up residence
at the school so that mexico's cream of
the crop mba students didn't leave he
wanted them to stay there and work for
mexico did the school make it it did for
a few years i guess i taught there six
years
but i think ultimately was absorbed into
maybe the university of monterey another
another institution of higher learning
it was very expensive he was pretty much
footing the bill
for the students but many of them went
on to fantastic careers i know some
ended up doing
graduate work beyond that at harvard
because i wrote recommendation letters
for them and they all have that spirit
of free enterprise and a sense they can
make a difference in the world
by the way you mentioned the wall street
journal you've written how many pieces
in the last couple years
well i just happen to know
in the last two years 15
and i think almost always the lead
op-ed which i appreciate very much
and who
first said to you yes
well through the years prior to that
maybe once or twice a year it would be
the person in charge of the editorial
page
is that paul you go
he is higher than that he has a higher
title um
the man is robert pollock and his uh his
partner is howard dickman they run the
page now
and um
i started getting a just a little email
do you have anything to say on this and
i think the first few times
now this is because my issue i'd written
a book called money meltdown back in 94.
and so we went through the mexican
meltdown after that in 95
asian in 98 russia 99
but whenever the us dollar has been
going through its throws of agony um
i would get a little inquiry but
especially a couple years ago a little
email what do you have to say about this
any thoughts
which is a dream come true when you get
a query and
i would say look you won't want it
because i'm kind of a curmudgeon on this
and
i wish we had a
neutral
reserve asset like goal something
universally recognized something that's
had constant purchasing power over
centuries
i mean this is crazy you you don't want
to put this as a lead op-ed on the
nation's premier business
newspaper
and he would write back yep sounds great
write it up
and and so i've had a chance um i don't
just
some people call me a gold bug but it's
not really that what i'm saying is
money is a tool it's not something
that's descended from heaven and yet we
live under legal tender laws of mandated
money you have to use
the dollar and i think that
implies
a moral contract on the part of
government if they're going to be the
producers of the dollar they better make
it a good product
to be a good product it has to fulfill
those functions of medium of exchange
unit of account and a store of value and
it has to do it honestly and with
reliability and with integrity do they
pay you to do that
or the journal yeah
i think it's gone over the years from
150 dollars
to
the one they ran a week or so ago i got
604 so
you could not make a living i asked you
for how many words
um usually 1200.
i want to go back in history again
because you had this
i don't know what you call this
relationship with russia back then and
um
with the wall coming down and
20 years of russia after let's let's
listen to what you had to say
i've always liked the literature tolstoy
and dostoevsky
and pushkin and goggle and
what i'm trying to do now is um
i'm trying to memorize
a day in the life of ivan de nisovich by
nitsan
so i i have tapes
of solzhenitsyn reciting his work
and then i have a russian russian or
english in russian
and then i have the work in russian and
i have it in english and i have about
four
english russian dictionaries and
every morning
for an hour
i start reciting what i've memorized so
far
and adding on to it and working my way
through the book why
it's
it's a great pleasure i
i think the way you you get a feel for
language unfortunately is through this
exercise of memorization
so
i need to hear it
and read it
and think about it so it has meaning to
me personally to really embrace it
how long was one day in the life of ivan
denisovich
how many pages
109 maybe
did you memorize it
um some of them yeah i have no idea
whether you were right or wrong
why were you doing that and have you
have you gone back to this do you still
read russian yes i i'm very interested
in dmitry medvedev
he's the president
i think he is different
from putin
i would love to see him be his own man
he's very much
against corruption
he appreciates the ideal of democracy
whether he can
rise to challenge putin
when it comes to that because i think it
would have to come to that i'll be very
anxious to see
um
but i read what he has to say virtually
every day the russian presidential
website is excellent
he has video of himself
russian and english so that's a good way
if you want to learn russian you can
read it in both languages you can watch
the video with with um
english beneath you can get transcripts
in in english and russian well before
you go any further let me show you
another clip because
things have changed a lot since then but
here's what you were doing back then at
your home out
an hour from washington
we
contracted with a gentleman who had set
up a satellite system
for colombia to listen in on soviet
television we set up
the same operation at our house
and it involves a big dish
and a little computer
and since the soviet
satellite is not
geostationary and i am not i don't know
anything about these things except what
was explained to me but the soviet
satellite keeps moving so the trick to
latch onto it is to get a system that
can follow it and track it
so our dish now wired to this computer
does a little search about every eight
minutes
figures out which is the strongest
direction the strongest signal and locks
onto that and follows out for a little
while
in the meantime feeds through
and in my office set up in the house i
can watch um color soviet television
from about 4 30 in the afternoon about 7
30 in the morning
that comes out of light of a stock
and then i get live soviet radio
straight out of moscow all day long so
it's a pleasure for me to hear the
language i enjoy that i don't pretend to
understand all of it but
i can get some of it and every once in a
while there's something interesting that
comes on the news
what happened to that system at your
home
i presume
the people who bought our house
dismantled it because i mean this was a
great big dish one time a military
helicopter just stayed near it i'm sure
taking pictures as i understood at one
time that there were only three such
setups and one was at
nsa and one was at cia and we had one so
but these days you can
you don't have to intercept
russian broadcasts which is which is
great um but that's interesting yeah
that was a real indulgence my husband
let me get that and i really did i love
to listen
at a certain time every day they would
go live to red square
and play
the soviet anthem
and that came out of world war ii when
they would try to reassure people
by radio
that the country was still there
and it actually is a beautiful anthem
and of course it was thrown out when the
soviet union ended but it was brought
back with different words
and i have to say it still is great
music but that's what you can hear now i
listen to voice of russia with earphones
now at my computer live
if you live in northern virginia
you can watch 24 hours a day seven days
a week russia today
a full-time television network in
english
with people that sound almost american
in some cases they might be or british
yeah as anchor people yeah have you seen
this and why are they doing this well
that is russia today is a
state-controlled
broadcast it looks a lot like our
american television oh i think they
actually probably tried to copy fox news
because it's
it just it just happens to be
state-run and you will find in in many
cases
similar type
stories at least the old pravda approach
under the soviet union was to highlight
whatever was the worst thing that
happened in the u.s
so if we had a natural disaster or
something embarrassing politically or
socially catastrophic someone walks into
a school and shoots 10 people boy that
would be on the news that's and and they
still tend to highlight that they ran a
huge feature last week on russia today
explaining why
this is just so irritating
um
uh 9 11
was
faked and
the u.s knew it and i mean just these
incendiary accusations and they do it as
investigative journalism well this
russia today is part of a package of 10
channels that
is supported by the state of virginia
and it's on a public television station
i
love that we can choose to watch those
things i found that the most useful
thing to me at the time i was working on
the soviet union when they were very
secretive was to have access to
state-controlled modes of information it
doesn't mean you can't learn a lot from
that you can learn a lot i go first to
voice of russia which is also state
controlled and often look at russia
today which is sort of as i say the
zippy version of what the state wants
you to hear and they will even throw in
stories that are sort of
critical of russia i think to make it
look like they're not
preordained from the government so they
do try to do that but
no i'm i'm happy i think those those
stations should be available you can
learn a lot by the way a government
wants to present itself the differences
you should also be listening to radio
echo moscovi
and some of the very few
media outlets out of russia that are
genuinely free it's it's the competitive
media that gives you a chance to make
for you to decide to hear the news and
then you to decide what's really
happening you were talking in your book
that we talked about 20 years ago about
the military and the money that
soviet unions all their focus was on the
military
20 years later this country spent 700
billion dollars in the new budget on
defense
and
you can hear people say that it's
all the rest of the world's military
combined
doesn't add up to 700 billion why are we
now in the position
of still being
this strong military country and do you
believe we should be well
just to put it in perspective that's
still
about four percent of our gross domestic
product and russia and the soviet union
in its final days was probably devoting
over 20 percent maybe 30 of its gross
domestic product to the military i mean
it was definitely a priority over
everything else
in this country people
don't like it to go above about four or
four percent
so um but but to your
larger question of why does the u.s have
to bear the burden
i don't think
i don't think americans are warmongers i
think we sort of
just shrug our shoulders and say
somebody
somebody has to do it i think we would
love it
if nato would take on more of the burden
but in the end we find that um
the us ends up looking or the rest of
the world ends up looking to the u.s
to
to
be the force for security it's too bad
it's it's an awful burden
and i i think it's um
i think the american people are generous
with their
people and with their treasure to
support it because i think most of the
things we do aren't just necessarily to
help ourselves i think they're to help
other countries
so
in the very few minutes we have left
what would you tell
this president and or anybody else
that's
responsible for the future
how to get out of this mess
out of afghanistan no out of the
financial mess around oh
well
first i think you go back to the source
of wealth in this country
which is
private business
and i think you change your attitude
and start saying we over tax people we
over burden with
regulatory requirements
we do not support
entrepreneurs and
and we don't give them sound money money
that doesn't inflate money that doesn't
put them into higher tax brackets than
they deserve but what do you say to
those that criticize
the fact that the regulators
were didn't do their job
in the last couple years i i think
that's totally misplaced totally
misplaced
i am so tired of the criticism of
this was even among republicans of wall
street greed or predatory lending
i think government had much more to do
with the financial crisis because
government interjected itself into the
private market
when government distorted
the the risk of fannie mae freddie mac
securities by sort of winking and saying
these are guaranteed
and then allow those to be sold and
resold and derivatives which are just
these same kind of financial bets
that multiplied by by 30 times over the
leverage of that small group of
bad risk subprime mortgages
it was the government
intervention and all that i mean let's
face it finance and banking are the most
heavily regulated industries we have you
can't
you can't regulate um
a distortion of of markets and and to
suggest that people were greedy because
they were pursuing profits
legally it was legal to make a profit by
selling derivatives selling them 10
times over it's perfectly legal but why
have an incentive system
that
makes it more profitable
to write up this complex financial
instrument
that's a bet of whether the european
central bank will move on interest rates
or the fed and they both keep their
deliberations secret or whether this
currency will rise or fall relative to
that currency instead of having one unit
of account
and not playing games with money why
would you set up an incentive system
that rewards people for betting on
so-called investments that have nothing
productive associated with them versus
people who make things or furnish real
services
they're saddled with having to pay when
a system like that built on financial
air collapses so i blame leaders for not
giving capitalism a sound monetary
foundation
and that would have provided the stable
financial atmosphere for carrying out
productive capitalism at a time how much
your time do you spend on the national
endowment for democracy
we have four
meetings a year i over i review our
projects so
i would say i probably spend uh 20
percent of my time including that we
don't have much time to go over but 80
of the time i think about international
monetary reform write about it work on
written projects i'm going to be at the
cato institute
monetary it's their 27th annual monetary
conference uh in a week or so another
book
um i'm not working well i'm working on a
book completely different
it's more on a religious theme and it's
fiction
so
judy shelton on that note we thank you
for joining us thanks so much
[Music]
for a dvd copy of this program call
[Music]
[Music]
as 1-877-662-7726 podcasts
[Music]